Did you ever wonder what it
would take for mobile devices
to use their camera to
understand their surroundings,
like we do?
Project Tango is a
computer vision platform
that can do that by
tracking motion, recognizing
spaces, and scanning
the surroundings in 3D.
My name is Nicolai
and in this episode,
we will talk about how motion
tracking gives mobile devices
the power to track fine grain
movement and move with you.
Motion tracking can follow
your motions smoothly,
whether you're standing,
walking or biking.
We found that it
works well on earth,
but we took the testing
one step further.
Project Tango was launched to
the International Space Station
as part of the SPHERES
robots program.
These were self-propelled robots
that floated around the space
station, and Project
Tango was integrated
to give live motion
tracking feedback.
In this episode, we are
going to share with you
how motion tracking
works and how
you can get started with it.
Imagine you had a virtual solar
system in your living room.
With motion tracking,
you could simply
walk from planet
to planet to have
a closer look at each of them.
Or you can use the device
to control a spaceship as it
descends and flies around on the
surface of one of the planets.
Whether you're building a
space game or something else,
you can use motion tracking
to take the user on a journey
through a virtual world.
So how does motion
tracking work?
Project Tango collects
data from a fisheye camera
and an inertial
measurement unit, or IMU.
The image from
the camera is used
to identify visual features,
such as edges and corners,
and track how much they move
between frames to determine
distance traveled.
This is called feature tracking.
The IMU uses an
accelerometer and a gyroscope
to track how fast a
device accelerates
and in which direction
it's turning.
Lastly, the images are fused
with the [INAUDIBLE] IMU
sensor data to calculate how
much the device has moved.
Did I mention that
this all happens
on the device, in real time,
and up to 100 times per second?
And since 60 images per second
is why motion tracking looks
smooth to the human eye, users
get a seamless sense of motion.
Now, one challenge is that the
human eye has a very wide field
of view, almost
180 degrees, which
greatly improves our ability to
see and run away from tigers.
So in order to increase
motion tracking accuracy
in mobile devices, Project Tango
uses wide angle fisheye lenses
at up to 160 degrees to capture
details of the environment.
Think about the
corner of a doorway.
It has high contrast and can
be easily identified over time.
For motion tracking
to work well,
we need to identify
many of these features
in the environment.
And the wider the
camera angle, the better
our chances to find
more such features,
which in turn increases the
reliability and accuracy
of motion tracking.
In order to use
motion tracking, you
need to understand Project
Tango's coordinate systems
and the concept of
frame of reference.
Project Tango tracks
the relative position
of the device in
three dimensions
from a starting point.
This point is called the origin,
and it's always zero-zero-zero.
The orientation of
the device is also
tracked around the
same three axes.
Since we can move and
rotate on each axis,
we end up with six degrees
of freedom in total.
Together, we refer
to the combination
of precision and orientation
as the device post.
The other important concept
is frame of reference.
In motion tracking,
everything happens
relative to where you start.
This is the origin.
The origin always coincides with
where you connect to and start
your Project Tango service.
We refer to the
frame of reference
as the start of service frame.
The start of service
frame in turn
relates to the
frame of the device.
When you combine
the two frames, you
get the position and orientation
of the device in space.
Project Tango supports many
more frames of reference,
but for motion tracking,
this is all you need.
Let's have a look at
Project Tango Explorer
to see how motion tracking
works in practice.
We are going to use Explorer in
its default mode, which shows
the raw motion tracking data.
The pyramid, also known
as the device frustum,
displays the orientation
of the device,
and the app shows the
position as a blue trace
when you move around.
If we walk in a
circle, the device
will show a circle
on the screen.
If we draw a circle with
the device in front of us,
you will see it works
in all three dimensions.
It is fundamental for
us to be able to move,
yet currently
available devices only
track orientation and
position at a coarse level.
Motion tracking in
Project Tango is
all about giving mobile devices
an understanding of movement
that fully tracks
the way we move.
Altogether, it lets the
device become a window
into a virtual space,
enables augmented reality,
and makes it possible to use the
device as a motion controller.
While we continue to improve
the robustness of the system,
APIs are available
so you can take
advantage of motion tracking and
build truly mobile experiences.
Visit our Google+ community
and join us on our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.